so I'm a couple of days ahead of footage
I know
sue me what are you gonna do okay first
time ever I managed to work ahead but it
looks like this is finally it the sub
gap is less than 4,000 which means by
the time this video goes up 50 series
will have passed me I know you're trying
I know you are because it has already
added now God that God is moving things
okay only your sinking ship here guys we
need to have a good life we need to have
a good skirt the florica um I found this
channel I watched the first video I'm
like oh that's that's there's multiple
channels gets hit by card walks away I
wonder what happens oh damn it
oh well series is already past it
doesn't matter nothing matters life
doesn't matter what are you gonna do cry
cry I'm gonna piss your pants maybe I am
maybe I am and I am doing that like
those bankers on Wall Street yeah the
top 1% just like doing dinner and and
come from middle-class working people
you goddamn right you got wrong yeah I
am
I mean I'm not you know
just kidding okay Jesus Christ no I
don't need this right now I need a good
life come on I don't even care about my
health bar oh you care if I die I'm
gonna laugh cuz I need it okay here we
go
god dammit Ricardo he could possibly be
the only one that can save us except we
already lost so you can't I can't do
this it hurts too much
hey look it's my channel before please
say we took over no not anymore feels
[Music]
you laugh you feel I hated me so uh give
me a good laugh please they say life can
cure any cancer let's make it happen
[Applause]
this is real I am so confused
Oh God Hey that was great smash Mike
okay guys next we have a picture of a my
name is snake my body long my head is
small but jaw is strong okay and when
it's time to get me fed I open wide and
launch the bread not cry okay
there's difference between tears of joy
and tears of satisfaction and when I see
a snake munch on something it makes me
attraction okay good
this free awesome not to be racist but
push queue oh god no I can't handle
anything more sad don't do it super
worthwhile super Wow
oh why are you guys so mean to me why
why it only works with oh I'm so I'm so
no no I did that with my other one no
you are not that dove Jesus Christ oh my
god that is disturbingly stupid what
would you say is a perfect man
[Laughter]
good me very very nice me I'm having a
great time by the way I don't know I'm
having a laugh yeah I don't care okay I
don't care I don't care anymore
I just don't know I have seen a security
hologram hey look at this killing young
young right there oh hi March I have
seen this video
please
[Music]
[Laughter]
but must be dying I must be dying watch
my house bar I guess I have a little
steam left in me huh oh no it's that
model what is that supposed to be a
horror game or something guys we have a
couple more epic Clips like stop crying
stop
oh my god are they gonna add another
layer now this is the kind of real
enthusiasm when I asked for a brofist ha
just kidding
you broke your screen for nothing it's a
Sbarro terminator Hey
see this is where the demo I think stop
for me I don't remember oh he doesn't
he's gotta wait maybe he there later man
all right all right you can buy some
time you can buy some time hey I'm gonna
just climb down this ladder
uh-huh I'm gonna just climb down this
letter
yeah that's great that was good life
[Music]
hey look it's diamonds that's nice no it
was only a dream just like I want to
wake up hit from t-series passing me
only being a nightmare to burst
simulator it's now so relevant that it's
got a brand new minigame Craney AK drop
the crane and get fresh items only
available in the washing machine like
game and you say there's more of course
there is new knowledge perks new quests
and new picks links and legs guys like